mrs vogel a request from the european council
after the approval vote of the
european parliament appointed president of
the european
commission i solemnly undertake in the
fulfillment of all my
duties to respect the treaties and the charter of fundamental rights of
the european union
my work in full independence
in the general interest of the  exercise union
in the performance of my duties
neither seek nor take instructions from any government, body, agency or any other body refrain from
any
action inconsistent with my office or the
performance of my duties
i accept the terms set out in the contract
governing the functioning of the  european
union commitment for
member states to respect this
independence and not to
seek to influence commission members
in the performance of their duties
i also
commit during and after the exercise  End of my
term of office
to perform the duties of my office,
in particular the duty to be honorable and restrained in accepting
certain posts or benefits
after the end of that post
[applause]
messi